Hello and welcome to today's Unreal Engine training on materials which is an introduction
for AEC.
So let's talk about the introduction.
Let's go over the topics that we'll be covering today.
So we'll be talking about real-time material concepts which is the PBR pipeline.
We'll be talking about the primary nodes and textures, so PBR inputs and texture guidelines.
We'll be going over the material system and talking about how parent materials and instances
of those materials works.
We've got ready-made materials and textures, so we'll go over where you can find starter
packs and marketplace assets and the Quixel Megascans library.
And then we'll go into authoring your own materials.
So we'll talk about the material editor.
We'll create a parent material and then we'll create an instance from that and show the
power of the material instance in.